hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com
so in today's video guys we're gonna go
through amcgme price action not a good
day at all we also gonna go uh through
uh what is happening on the global
market triple q and as usual guys
quickly we're gonna check what is
happening on the oil market which is
very important and on the u.s 10-year
yield let's get into it
oh right so
bam bam bam um amc guys minus seven
percent i'm here on the first time frame
let's go on a daily timeframe
so we are still for those who watched
the video i did yesterday
uh we are still in this wedge pattern
all right
a wedge pattern is just you know kind of
a
i would say
it looks like a triangle but the
difference between a wedge and a
triangle is that the triangle is a
corrective pattern so when you move down
a triangle will have a basis that is
going higher all right a wedge has a
basis that is going lower and
a resistance
line trendline that is going lower as
well so it gives us this kind of
patterns they are usually reversal
patterns why are the reversal patterns
because
a wedge is characterized by the fact
that the price action is slowing all
right which means that as you can see
here we're moving sharply down and here
we are still moving lower but slower
this can also be seen in the momentum
indicators so here on the daily time
frame we only see the momentum so rsi or
macd
slowing but we don't see it uh going up
so we don't have a bullish divergence on
the daily timeframe but we have this
bullish divergence on the first time
frame and like i told you guys yesterday
a bullish divergence without another
bullish signal such as a candlestick
pattern a breakout
moving averages cross over is not a
signal that you can use for training
i mean you could here for example this
is a good example
so it's not the perfect situation to do
that but another way to trade bullish
divergences is just to wait
for a support to be hit
with the momentum going higher so
here
we are on
a support uh which is the support
created by the
lower band of my watch pattern and we
still have the bullish divergence so
technically i could set up a bullish
order here with a stop loss just here if
it was not amc of course amc we don't
use stop losses and to be honest i
personally didn't buy in this area
uh because i'm waiting for a breakout i
i don't want to take the risk to buy
here when let's be honest we could still
have more downside to come
when i could buy a little bit higher but
with
a higher probability of reversal so this
is what i'm personally trying to do
so as you can see yesterday i was
telling you we had that bullish
divergence and still today we are
dropping why because we didn't have that
short-term bullish signal that we were
waiting for i told you guys yesterday i
did the strength line with you guys i
showed you how to do it and quite
interestingly this morning this is
exactly where we had the rejection
so you could tell me that the 17 area
the 17 level was already a resistance
natural resistance what i call natural
is whenever it's created by a recent
lows of recent highs as you guys can see
here we had one two three four five six
recent
lows or recent highs so 17 was a radio
resistance but it was also where
i had this trend line coming and right
now guys we are in a situation that
very honestly is looking like it's gonna
reverse all right so i know that i've
been saying that amc will reverse uh you
know for quite some time
uh in this whole move down i was really
hoping that at 21 we have this bullish
reaction we didn't since here i'm
telling you guys that um we are a bit
neutral the third wave you know it's
still on the table but the probability
of the third wave has clearly decreased
because bulls lost control on the long
term here after we went below the 61.8
retracement of this first move up okay
i'm not gonna do it again i did that uh
dozens of time okay i do it again so you
can see here the 61.8 was here so it was
even here guys so since we broke out
below 21 we are not bullish anymore uh
for now on the long term and we are
looking for a
bullish reversal for this
new move up to start and we're gonna
then see if it's potentially a third
wave which means that we could go to 70
or if it is just
a correction uh off
uh
you know inside this whole move down if
you just you know correction on the way
up because we are here bearish guys all
right
so in moves down corrective moves happen
on the upside so the question we're
gonna have once we finally you know make
this um rebound so once again
are we gonna go to 13 before making it
i don't know it really doesn't look like
it but for now we can't deny that buzz
and control on pretty much every time
frame guys
uh the only good thing once again that
we have is this kind of good situation
for reversal that we have on a forest
timeframe why is it a good situation for
a reversal
um
because
for reversal to happen we like to have a
nice consolidation on low volume and
guys a nice consolidation is created by
multiple reactions on some supports or
some resistances in a tight range all
right
i've been saying that for quite some
time i told you guys that doing that the
consolidation was here then we moved
lower
but here once again we've never had
those bullish signals which we are
looking for which is a breakout with
increasing volume
we never had it
i can tell you that whatever we're going
to have it just like here
the probability of a strong move up is
going to be very high uh for now we
don't have that and bears are getting
ground once again this is also due to
what is happening on the rest of the
market but let me here conclude what we
are looking for and yeah so here first
this is a bullish uh i mean a reversal
situation but once again as long as we
don't have the breakout the reversal is
not that likely to happen but
we're in a situation where if this
breakout happens it's going to be easy
to have it with increasing volume
because the volume is very low
and
now yesterday i told you that this
trendline was not that perfect because i
was i was missing some reactions on the
short term i have today one more
reaction so it's a better trend than
yesterday and we are now really
converging towards this you know wedge
um
[Music]
you know this bottom of the wedge so
let's see what's gonna happen we can
also break out on the downside it's it
would not be nice
but it's still possible
it would depend a lot on what is
happening on the rest of the market
that's why i will analyze triple q very
soon
here to conclude there is one more thing
i wanted to show you guys is that i told
you the 16.3 level is an important level
because it's the breakout level so
you're going to tell me it was last
month yes but i can tell you that a lot
of investors still remember that level
because this is the level where big nice
things have started so it's in
everyone's mind and right now bears kind
of um offset this whole move up and we
are back to this level so it's important
for uh
for bulls to show their strengths here
uh and today what we're having is a
breakout below this level okay so once
again we're having a breakout as you can
see this far scandal went through the
16.3 level that acted very well as
support um the past two candles i mean
yesterday and the day before
and
and friday
and so uh it has been broken today
so it's not a good thing but
what i've noticed guys with amc and i'm
sure you have noticed it too is that we
very often have a bear trap before
reversal remember guys here the level
was 14.5
okay
or 14.
okay i've been having this level for a
very long time and i told you that at
this level we should have a bullish
reaction here we set up a few bullish
trades in my discord and um
and then we had here this breakout i
don't know if you guys remember i was
here a bit you know
really not happy because
it was important that this level uh hold
for uh what happened afterwards and look
we had here this bear trap so that's why
now i moved my trendline here but i
remind you guys that we were like here
we had a close on the daily timeframe
below the 14 level which was not looking
good and the next day we started a
massive rally
so
usually when i see this kind of
breakouts
so first the breakout occurs on low
volume so i should not pay too much
attention to it
but if i had seen here a volume i would
have said all right this is bearish and
we are likely to go to 13. but amc
situation is different you guys know
that many algorithms uh work on the
stock and
manipulate this i mean this market is
manipulated more than any other market
so here it could be just maybe one more
trap before a rebound i don't know if
it's going to happen i'm just saying
that if we
manage to have this breakout here
above this trend line we finally this
increase in volume guys that we are
looking for for the past month
then it would be looking very good and
we would need to analyze what happens on
the way up in terms of volume in terms
of volatility
um to try to predict if we are gonna
move strongly higher or not but let's be
honest it's gonna be very hard to
predict um until it happens all right so
if we go to 2126 this area then
i can tell you bears will start to be
scared and bulls will probably gather
their strengths and we could have some
nice things happening all right but for
now we're not there guys so we're
looking for this breakout above the 16.8
level with increase in volume and then
we can see what can happen next for now
the next support level guys is at 13
so
let's see i hope this is only a fake out
then jamie
so
uh pam pam pam gme regular scale all
right
what do we have here let me get rid of
that pom pom pam okay so we are here uh
back to this level so it was a little
bit expected
uh we discussed that yesterday guys and
i mean it was a bit
expected that gme
goes lower once again because we broke
out below the 141.5 level and um
[Music]
and we needed to find some more support
at this important level that is 130 and
i told you that you could have some
access to 123 which is the 61.8 fib
ratio right now we are below the 120
level which is not looking so good but
look at the volume guys
seriously i mean whenever the market is
moving with big moves the volume is
always a little bit animated so i know
the day is not over
but
you know the market is closing in two
hours and we still have this very very
low volume on a quite brutal day guys
minus five percent
so this is only telling me that guys
what is happening right now
is um
only traded by a few investors so most
investors that just wait right they
don't want to trade this market whatever
the position they have is just booze uh
you know holding the ground and bears
are holding the ground bears are
actually taking some ground uh but
whatever we're still bullish on the long
term guys we still have this very low
volume that is easy to i would say go
against whenever bulls gonna decide
finally to buy this market which once
again is probably gonna come
from some macroeconomics reasons
more than uh amc or gme
so jamie is still looking good on the
long term we have reached this area that
i think we needed to go to to find some
buyers waiting here probably so not sure
they're going to step in today or
tomorrow um
i would prefer to be honest to close
above that 120 level on the daily
timeframe
in the same way i would prefer we close
above 16.3 on amc but once again we've
seen those fake outs many times
i'm not too worried when i just look at
jme what is worrying me guys as you know
and unfortunately amc and jamie will
follow if
triple q thanks all right so let's
discuss that a bit guys
um
so let me quickly remind you guys the
situation let's take even a bigger step
back guys okay i just want to show you i
remove all my drawings
bam
you know
i just want to show you guys that we've
been correcting
for the first time since march 20. so
it's
i would say um something that the market
needed to correct we have uh you know
everything um combined for this
correction to happen we have the rates
going higher we have a wall we have a
weaker growth we have the coving that is
spreading again in china
and we have of course the inflation that
is actually the reason why the rates are
going higher in this weak growth
environment usually when the
growth is weak or expected to be weak
the fed is keeping the rates low so that
the economy can sustain and um keep
developing but now they have no other
choice than just
increasing the rates to tackle inflation
and this is the first time we're in the
situation for quite some time guys so uh
yeah what i wanted to show is that this
correction was kind of expected and the
question we're having is where this can
go all right and um
since we have the breakout that is here
guys clearly identified once again
this was the signal for me that things
are bloody i posted an alert right away
guys we
made some good money
here in this whole move down guys
hopefully because i can tell you that i
didn't make good money on the rest of my
investments but this play saved
everything because once again this is a
protection that you know we can uh trade
against our long position this is what
i've been doing i'm still short on this
market because i'm long on different
stocks
um rather flatish right now in this
environment i don't have a short
position i missed uh to create a real
short position which means that my short
term triple q will be
covering the losses plus making profits
uh of
the losses of my other investments plus
making profits i missed this thread
because 338 which was the support level
that i told you guys if broken will give
us a move down usually those supports
after being broken are re-tested here we
didn't have the re-tests
it's not
the usual way things happen usually i
would say eighty percent seventy eighty
percent of the time we have the retest
uh but in terms of risk rewards guys
what i've noticed is that it's better to
wait here than just selling here because
the risk reward you're going to miss it
sometimes like i did here but most of
the time the risk reward is going to be
better if you just sell on the retest
with the stop loss just higher so this
is what i tried to do i missed it so
today in my discord i just said
for those who are really short you can
buy 319 y319 as you can see because it's
the trendline that fits the best the
recent lows
um
and so sorry 318 not 319 and uh we went
today to
319 and we have a little rebound but
uh i would personally not build a long
position here so as i'm rather flatish
on all of my investments
i would just do nothing here all right
and
uh what i'm afraid guys
uh given the strong moves that we are
seeing for the past two three days is
that we are accelerating on the down
center right so this is one scenario
uh if i only look at triple q guys is a
little bit the most likely scenario i
gave you here some probabilities so the
more we go lower the lower so this was a
priority i gave uh whenever we broke out
here so uh i said that moving sideways
is the most likely scenario but of
course the lower we come here the higher
this probability gets so right now
uh i don't know what's gonna happen i
will personally not buy 320 318 i will
take a little bit of profits here at
three or eight
and uh
i'm afraid we go there guys let's be
honest uh and once we are at 280 then i
will start buying like really buying all
right not uh
just
taking profits on my short position but
buying
and um why 280 guys 282 because
uh pom-pom pam yeah it's the one-to-one
projection
is it
what's that
no it's not the one to one projection
y280 i have here some reactions
and it's probably coming from something
else let me measure here this whole move
up
up
because this is what we are correcting
right so we can apply the same methods
okay so as you can see here
315 is the 38.2 percent it has been
reached already
so this correction could be over because
a correction
needs to go at least to the 38.2 percent
but most corrections they go to do 15
61.8 only on stocks on the global market
we don't see often 61.8 but so here my
take is that this correction is going to
be a little bit deeper so the 285 area
is the area that i think we're going to
and in this area the best support i
found was 282 so this is the reason why
282 is
my target for this correction
and we are just heading towards the most
likely scenario once again that i have
presented guys a very long time ago is a
massive wxy complex correction that is
going to last a few more months
bam w x y okay and uh that in june july
we then finally have uh this really uh
you know this bounce
uh on the global market so this is
unfortunately my preferred scenario from
here i still have some hope that
we move sideways or even are bullish and
make new highs quicker than expected but
for now this is more looking bearish in
this situation of course amc and jamie
will drop a little bit more and we will
only have a strong rebound happening in
june july so um we're gonna analyze that
for now as long as we hold
above 320
318 which is the recent low
i mean there is
there is a case for bulls to you know
take back control let's be honest but as
you guys know
uh the
more a support is tested the weaker it
gets it has been tested once twice three
times it's been the first time we're
getting here
so
i'm a bit afraid we uh go through that
level in the coming weeks uh but for now
once again we are coming close to
support so we can hope for a rebound and
if we have this rebound uh then
very likely uh
amc will finally break out here all
right so i'm monitoring that because
we're gonna have one shot here and the
next shot is gonna be here and then here
so each time we're gonna be close to
this areas uh it's gonna be a nice
opportunity for the global market to
rebound which means it's gonna be a nice
opportunity for both to take back
control on amc and gme and at uh and
whenever they're gonna take back control
finally guys they're probably gonna
take some nice ground and we're gonna
have a nice rebound so this is uh what
i'm gonna try to uh trade personally
and to conclude guys uh of course we
keep an eye on the u.s 10-year yield
because i told you guys that you know
this is representing uh the inflation
this is also representing the expected
returns of business
in the next 10 years so it's basically
the higher it is the tougher it is for
equity
to over perfor to outperform this rate
right so if it's very high in
an inflationary environment which is the
case
this is not good for markets
and right now
we are we had a breakout on the weekly
timeframe above this 285 level and we
don't want this breakout to be confirmed
once again this breakout occurred
without any consolidation so it's very
likely that bears just attack it and
that we get rejected if we see this kind
of move this would be very good for the
global market so i expect this is the
scenario for now it's pretty good we can
see it's stabilized
but this friday guys because this is a
weekly timeframe this friday is going to
be very important for this breakout to
be validated or not validated i mean
confirmed or not confirmed
um yeah and that's pretty much it guys
for today thank you very much once again
for those who have watched the
video i made on skylandia and who gave
me a like only 50 of you uh went there
but it's still helping me thank you so
much this sunday guys i had a
collaboration with a big nft project so
i'm gonna make a video about them and i
really want you guys to go watch this
video so get prepared it's going to be
this sunday i told uh the project that
we're gonna that i'm gonna have around
500 to 1000 views so i need at least 500
views once again guess this is going to
be good for the crypto bull project
because it's going to help me to
collaborate with other big projects and
once again guys as trading sensors
members you can join the cryptobuild
project and get um the early bull road
which is going to give you access
for the best price to mint the nfts
whenever it's going to be available
within one or two month maximum i'm
gonna explain better what um actually
we're gonna do in crypto booths but guys
we are making something totally totally
unique
and very very serious project that i'm
working on with some very very um
strong um people that helped me in this
project so uh i'm gonna tell you more
about that once again thank you very
much for those who have liked the video
yesterday i asked you to for those who
haven't go it's still helping me if you
do it today and i can't on you guys on
sunday whenever i'm gonna post the video
about the collab which is the first
collab i'm gonna make with another nft
project so thank you very much for
watching guys and
um and please give me a like if you have
not liked this video already so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to show see
you guys